[Music]
hi holly are you there hi
i'm here how are you ladies are you
doing great how are you
pretty good bless thank you absolutely
how can we help
well i am currently reworking our budget
um our income just about quadrupled with
my husband finishing school oh wow
debt-free by the way we've got no
student loans
thank you
um so i'm a little overwhelmed with the
change but i guess my main question
is
as a stay-at-home mom
should i be getting some sort of
allowance how do i account for
my spending money and out in our budget
based on his income oh
i have some thoughts on this holly i
have some thoughts based on how you ask
the question jump in
how do i get an allowance
holly
this is not your husband's money
this is y'all's money
you're married you're correct
yes okay
are the children just your children are
they his children too no no no we've got
um one son together and we've got one on
the way okay congratulations and
when you walk down the aisle you became
one you decided to share your life your
time your money your children all the
things so i want to break this idea that
you are getting money from your spouse
that you are one with that you're
getting an allowance or spending money
even how you asked it i think the
premise of that
is off because it's not his money it's
y'all's money and by the way we were
just talking about this
on the blinds.com question but there is
an unbelievable cost of child care if
you were to replace yourself
through child care and run the numbers
of two kids in child care that alone at
the baseline is the value the financial
dollar amount that you're bringing to
your family on paper on the budget so i
want to start by just questioning the
premise of how do i get money from him
this this to me is not even a question
this is y'all's money and y'all like we
were just saying
together yeah and and holly i'm i'm
assuming i don't well i don't want to
assume so i'll ask you are you feeling
are you guys feeling overwhelmed when
you said he quadrupled his income so you
guys are making
more money than you probably ever even
imagined
so is that feeling very overwhelming to
you
um a little bit because i just want to
make sure that we're doing the right
things with the money and we've been
following the baby steps and um always
all the debt we have actually i paid off
one of our car notes yesterday
and so all we've got is um just my car
now left to pay off and i want to be
clear that um
he doesn't
feel that this is his money it is
totally understood that this is our
money
my main question i guess is just
more of a budget perspective of what
does it look like yes budget yeah so
what i would say for you guys since you
are coming in to
more money than than you've had right um
is to increase your lifestyle a little
bit at a time
so the budget that you guys have been
having
just up some categories 10 20
maybe even just 10 depending on the
dollar amount and say okay i'm gonna
we're going to up that miscellaneous
we're going to up out to eat we're you
need to get out of debt first first and
foremost all that all that cash but yeah
this is this is once kind of that is all
paid off which i'm assuming is going to
happen very quickly
and and to be able to say okay yes i you
have a line item in the budget he has a
line in the budget and it may feel weird
at first like okay we're gonna up these
dollar amounts
um but you're gonna be able to because
you're gonna have the margin once you're
debt debt-free and you have that
emergency fund in place to be able to do
that and so do it slowly over time
because you're not gonna it's gonna feel
out of control if you're like okay let's
just live on this and it's gonna feel
great and we're just gonna go at it
that's a little bit where the insecurity
can happen for a while so yes absolutely
so just wade into it
and get used to it and then also holly
making sure that you're up and you're
giving as well
and so
the lifestyle can be upped a little bit
and the giving and both of these things
is going to really
start to allow these new habits to form
on how to handle and steward really what
god has given you guys in an amazing way
but again holly
getting out of debt that emergency fund
that needs to be
first priority before anything else but
then to be able to say hey yeah we each
get some some fun money and there
shouldn't be guilt for that yeah when
you have a conversation and you're both
represented in the budget then you're
putting on paper that you both have
value in the budget and you do and
that's going to be a fun conversation
now that you have so much more money
absolutely